we saw you at the 2011 film Independent
Spirit Awards yes on the red carpet and
it seems like you've been on sort of a
whirlwind
since then all sorts of different things
going on and and I'm sure everything
looks good from far away but I'm
wondering what does someone behind the
scenes maybe struggle with in terms of
whether it's just their own dealings
with success or could have nothing to do
with acting what has it been - being
busy or is there anything that you're
sort of working with that
oh that maybe we don't see oh goodness
um well I mean you know it's it has been
a whirlwind and it's been I mean you
know I study theatre NYU I purposely
went to college to have longevity as an
actress and to have a run at it and
study where I came from and I'm so happy
for that training because you know with
a role like Nell what's incredible about
the horror genre now is it breaks you
out so much it's such an experimental
genre it's so much is required of you
physically and emotionally and you're
pushed out of your comfort zone and
that's where things get fun as an
actress you know and I think what I'm
most grateful about is that because I
played a role like now it's allowed me
to play other strong females I mean now
even though she's vulnerable she
maintains this hope that she'll get
better everything will be okay under
under situations that are completely out
of her control and I love that about her
you know I I went on to do an action
film called the day which was great to
play that kind of kick-ass shot gun
slinging you know heroine um I didn't
bounce back I did film called the bounce
back with Bryan poised or another Spirit
Award winner and I also have a couple
other films coming out called the marine
which is action and sparks which is
straight action and you know it broke me
out like that and getting a chance to
play these roles is is you know it's a
true privilege right I remember from a
prior interview that you did for the day
you said
at the role of Mary yes she was she was
a challenge and maybe it was a character
that a lot of people wouldn't like but
you really found things in her that you
liked and that it did push you out of
your comfort zone and that's always been
there's a saying by Seth Godin that sort
of the work that you fear that you put
off is really the work that you need to
do so when you find something that is
out of your comfort zone how do you
approach that if something is out of my
comfort zone and it feels dangerous in
terms of a role it really attracts me I
want to dive in and in diving in it
helps me to dive in through research you
know to prep for the role of Mary the
director kind of tried to talk me out of
doing it and a bunch of other actresses
they were like you're gonna have to lose
weight you're gonna have to shave your
head you're gonna have to do your own
stunts it's gonna be freezing and I I
kind of replied back you haven't given
me a reason not to do this role this
sounds incredible um you know to get
that to get at my age you know and to be
a young actress to get that place to to
transform like that it's really exciting
for me and going back to the Last
Exorcism you know for the first film I
researched a lot into exorcisms and
demonic possessions and I watched video
and I listened to tapes and in watching
things and seeing people kind of well
their bodies became inhabited by
something else I'd read a quote their
bodies became a battleground for the
devil and it kind of inspired me and I
said what would that look like and as I
was doing my homework and researching I
tried it out and that's how I found that
backbend and it was the night before
that expert says I'm seeing Daniel Stamm
the director had said do you have
anything you want to try and I said well
I have this backbend and he said okay
you stay there I'm gonna change some
things and I had I had no idea it would
become the image for two posters and
such this iconic look
you